desde la plataforma somos muchas
abrazamos y reconocemos como propias las
recomendaciones que hacer comité de las
he dado desde nuestra plataforma
participamos en este proceso de la
sesión 83 de la sedado tanto presentando
un informe sombra así como parte de la
delegación oficial de las organizaciones
de sociedad civil para poder poner en el
mapa internacional Cuál es la situación
de las mujeres y niñas en nuestro país
reconocemos que actualmente la Corte
Suprema de Justicia tiene una
oportunidad de cambiar esto y hacer caso
a las recomendaciones de las Naciones
Unidas al poder pronunciarse
favorablemente ante el recurso
inconstitucionalidad que desde somos
muchas y organizaciones sociales aliadas
interpusimos y fue admitido hace un año
sin embargo todavía no tenemos un fallo
que pueda permitir que el aborto esté
penalizado mínimo por las tres causales
que conocemos
en tema de la pae esperamos que el
gobierno Así que como en el aborto
puedan pronunciarse de manera favorable
ya que esto no sólo fue una promesa de
campaña sino que está por el plan de
gobierno de nuestra presidenta semana
Castro es por eso que Esperamos que
todos los retrocesos que hemos tenido
lastimosamente de los últimos años en
materia de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos puedan retornar de la
misma manera que la democracia en estos
próximos meses y años
Asimismo comentarte que de la plataforma
somos muchas hemos realizado un informe
sobre la criminalización del aborto
donde hemos encontrado que el personal
de salud suele ser el principal
ente que denuncia Estas mujeres por
tanto Esperamos que también pueda haber
un respeto al secreto profesional médico
Andrea aparte del personal De salud cómo
ha sido la actitud por ejemplo de las
autoridades políticas y judiciales
frente a los intentos por despenalizar
el aborto en Honduras
como te comentaba actualmente Tenemos la
oportunidad con la Corte Suprema de
Justicia Sin embargo a más de un año y a
pesar de que es algo urgente porque
todos los días las mujeres y niñas nos
vemos afectadas por esta prohibición
absoluta del aborto en un país donde a
diario y según cifras de la misma secre
de salud tres niñas menores de 14 años
están dando a luz no hemos visto un
avance sin embargo
Esperamos que pueda haber Porque
definitivamente los argumentos jurídicos
médicos sociales están ahí y solo
Esperamos que se puedan pronunciar en
los próximos meses para poder cambiar
esta Absurda y muy hostil en realidad de
las mujeres